THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
JOE BIDEN FINALLY RESPONDING TO
MOUNTING ALLEGATIONS OF
INAPPROPRIATELY TOUCHING WOMEN.
FOUR NOW SPEAKING ABOUT THE
FORMER VP'S BEHAVIOR WITH TWO
MORE COMING FORWARD LAST NIGHT.
BIDEN ADDRESSING THE ALLEGATIONS
EARLIER.
>> TRYING TO MAKE A HUMAN
CONNECTION.
THAT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY.
I SHAKE HANDS.
I GRABBED PEOPLE.
I GRABBED MEN AND WOMEN BY THE
SHOULDERS AND SO YOU CAN DO
THIS.
WHETHER THEY ARE WOMEN, MEN,
YOUNG, OLD, IT'S THE WAY HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN.
IT'S THE WAY I'VE TRIED TO SHOW
THAT I CARE ABOUT THEM AND I'M
LISTENING.
SOCIAL MORES HAVE BEGAN TO
CHANGE.
THEY HAVE SHIFTED.
THE BOUNDARIES OF PROTECTING
PERSONAL SPACE HAVE BEEN RESET
AND I GET IT.
I WILL BE MORE MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF PEOPLE'S PERSONAL
SPACE.
THE IDEA THAT I CAN ADJUST TO
THE FACT THAT PERSONAL SPACE IS
IMPORTANT, MORE IMPORTANT THAN
IT'S EVER BEEN.
I WILL.
>> Jesse: LET'S GO TO THE
DEMOCRAT AT THE TABLE.
MR. WILLIAMS.
NOT THE SMOOTHEST ROLLOUT FOR
MR. BIDEN.
THE INDECISION, THE APOLOGY
TOUR, NOW THE WOMEN.
HOW DO YOU THINK HE'S DOING SO
FAR?
>> Juan: I THINK HE SHOULD DO
AN INTERVIEW.
THE PAPER STATEMENT IN THE
VIDEO, IT STRIKES ME IS
INSUFFICIENT AND NOT UP TO THE
MOMENT.
I THINK DANA HAS MADE THE POINT
THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE A CAMPAIGN
SO HE DOESN'T HAVE A CAMPAIGN
APPARATUS, A COMMUNICATIONS
SHOP, SPOKESMAN WHO COULD BE
HELPING HIM.
I KNOW HE DOES HAVE STAFF.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
FOR ME, I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SAY
-- SEE JOE BIDEN COME OUT AND
SPEAK TO IT AND NOT ENGAGE IN
WHAT LOOKS LIKE HIDING BUYING
THE CAMERA BECAUSE HE'S JUST
DOING A VIDEO AND THROWING IT
OUT THERE.
TO ME, THE DIFFICULTY FOR
JOE BIDEN IS THAT IT OPENS THE
DOOR TO THE ANITA HILL QUESTION
AND HOW HE HANDLED ANITA HILL.
IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM THAT MAKES HIM
OUT TO BE A GUY WHO IS OUT OF
TOUCH WITH THE TIMES.
I THINK COMING FROM THE LEFT
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
BUT I DON'T TICKETS
DISQUALIFYING WHICH IS WHAT
NANCY PELOSI, THE SPEAKER, SAID.
IT'S NOT DISQUALIFYING BUT AT
THIS POINT, YOU FEEL FOR JOE.
I DON'T THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
COMMENTS IN WHICH HE SAID
WELCOME -- HOW DO YOU LIKE YOUR
LIFE NOW, JOE?
I THINK TRUMP AND SOME
REPUBLICANS UNFORTUNATELY
JOINING HIM IN THIS, MAKING IT
OUT LIKE THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GRABBING WOMEN
IS ASSAULT.
WHAT JOE BIDEN DID IS AT BEST
INAPPROPRIATE.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH SEX.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE THAT SOUND
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE ONLY NONSORT OF HEAVY
SOCIALIST IS BEING TAKEN CARE OF
PRETTY WELL BY THE SOCIALISTS.
THEY GOT TO HIM.
OUR FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
I WAS GOING TO CALL HIM -- I
DON'T KNOW THEM WELL.
I WAS GOING TO SAY WELCOME TO
THE WORLD, JOE.
ARE YOU HAVING A GOOD TIME, JOE?
>> Jesse: I THINK HE IS SAYING
IT'S PRETTY ROUGH OUT THERE.
>> Kennedy: ESPECIALLY NOW IN
THIS POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
JOE BIDEN MIGHT HAVE RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
1988?
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE IT IS
SO DIRTY.
THIS IS ALSO A KNOWN QUANTITY
AND THE PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT SOME OF
JOE'S FOES ARE PLAYING THE
TOUCHING CARD THIS EARLY.
OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO KEEP THEM
OUT SO WE CAN'T LAND THOSE
BIG-MONEY DONORS EARLY ON.
BECAUSE HE'S AT THE HEAD OF THE
PACK RIGHT NOW.
HE'S THE BIGGEST THREAT NOT ONLY
TO THE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE RACE
BUT TO THE PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE IN
THE RACE AND WHAT THEY STAND
FOR.
WHAT THEY ARE WILLING TO DO TO
DISMANTLE THE ESTABLISHMENT IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Jesse: JUAN DIDN'T THINK
THE VIDEO WAS EFFICIENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: WE HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS AS A LEAD STORY SINCE
MONDAY, PROBABLY NOT HANDLING IT
WELL IN TERMS OF GETTING OVER
IT.
THERE'S BEEN NO OTHER BIG NEWS
THIS COME OUT.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT JOE BIDEN OR
PEOPLE RUNNING TO RUN AGAINST
HIM, WAITING FOR HIS BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT.
I THINK THE VIDEO THING TODAY,
MAYBE THAT HELPS PUT IT TO BED A
LITTLE BIT.
I ABSOLUTELY THINK IT'S
CALCULATED AND COORDINATED.
THE HEADLINE THIS MORNING, TWO
MORE WOMEN CAME OUT.
TOMORROW WILL BE TOMORROW.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DID TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I CAN SEE
WHY HE WAS LIKE, HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE IT NOW?
THIS IS THE OTHER THING.
WHAT DO WE TALK ABOUT WHEN WE
SAY PEOPLE LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WHY?
AUTHENTIC.
JOE BIDEN IS NOW BASICALLY BEING
TOLD YOU CANNOT BE YOUR
AUTHENTIC SELF AND RUN AS
JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TURN HIM INTO
A STIFF ARM ROBOT.
>> Kennedy: PRETEND LIKE I
HAVE A COLD.
>> Dana: THAT'S JUST NOT WHO
WE IS.
HIS POLLING IS HELD UP PRETTY
WELL EVEN THOUGH HE DOESN'T HAVE
A CAMPAIGN.
ACROSS THE BOARD, HE'S ALWAYS
THE NUMBER ONE DEMOCRAT, BEING
ASKED WHO DO YOU WANT TO RUN AND
WHO DO YOU THINK AND BEAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
IT'S ALWAYS JOE BIDEN.
MAYBE THERE'S OTHER REASONS FOR
THAT.
HE HASN'T TAKEN VERY MANY WAX.
SEEMS LIKE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE DESPERATE TO GET HIM OUT.
I WOULDN'T COUNT HIM OUT.
I THINK HE CAN OVERCOME IT.
>> Jesse: FOR SOME
PERSPECTIVE, HE HAS MET PROBABLY
A MILLION PEOPLE IN TEN YEARS.
FOUR WOMEN SAID THEY FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THIS WAS NOT SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THIS WAS NOZZLEGATE.
>> Greg: PERMISSION TO DO A
CORNY JOKE?
WHY DO THESE WOMEN WAIT SO LONG
TO COME OUT?
MAYBE THEY WERE BIDEN THEIR
TIME.
>> Dana: VERY GOOD.
>> Greg: THE STORY, IT
SHOULDN'T BE A TWO IDEA PRISON.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT.
YOU CAN SAY HE SHOULDN'T BE
DOING THIS SORT OF THING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULDN'T BE
TRYING TO DESTROY HIM EITHER
SIMPLY BECAUSE HE'S IN THE WAY.
THEY'RE WILLING TO DESTROY KIND
OF A LASTING MEMORY OF WHO THIS
PERSON IS BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T WANT THIS OLD WHITE GUY
AROUND ANYMORE.
THEY ARE WILLING TO THEM ASIDE.
THIS WAS ALL KNOWN.
NOW IT MATTERS NOW.
FOR ME, HE SHOULDN'T BE DOING IT
BUT IT WOULD BE NICE FOR THIS
ATTACK NOT TO WORK BECAUSE TO
YOUR POINT, IT'S DEAFLY BEING
RUN BY A PRO.
THIS DRIP, DRIP, DRIP, WHO'S
NEXT.
IT'S GOT THAT MEDIA MATTERS FEEL
TO IT WHERE IT MIGHT BE A
CONJOINED ORCHESTRATION BETWEEN
LIKE A GROUP AND MEDIA MATTERS.
IN SUCH A CALCULATED TAKE-OUT.
IT'S A POINT WHERE BOTH PARTIES
COULD UNITE AND SAY DO YOU THINK
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO STOP THIS
CRAP?
WE ARE BASICALLY RUINING
PEOPLE'S LIVES OVER POLITICS.
MEANWHILE YOU LOOK AT VIRGINIA,
YOU STILL HAVE -- WE STILL
DIDN'T KNOW WHO WAS IN
BLACKFACE.
THE GOVERNOR IS STILL THERE.
THERE IS SOME SEXUAL ASSAULT
CLAIMS THAT ARE PRETTY
DISTURBING.
WHERE ARE THE DEMOCRATS
PRIORITIES ON THAT?
IT'S DEFINITELY POLITICALLY
CALCULATED, MOTIVATED.
>> Juan: YOU SAID OLDER WHITE
MALE, AND THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT IT.
YOU KNOW THE SUSPICION TO YOUR
STANDARDS IS BERNIE SANDERS --
HE'S JUST RAISED A RECORD AMOUNT
OF MONEY.
TO DANA'S POINT, IT'S NOT ALL
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
JOE BIDEN.
AS YOU POINT OUT, HE'S I THINK
CLOSE TO 30% OF GROUPS OF
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY
EITHER HIS OPPONENTS WHO ARE
TRYING TO PREEMPT HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT OR SECONDLY, THAT
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT.
THERE IS A REAL ISSUE WITH HOW
MEN TREAT WOMEN AND GUESS WHAT,
I'M SENSITIVE TO IT.
IT'S NOT SAYING WE DON'T LIKE
JOE BIDEN.
>> Kennedy: DO YOU THINK THOSE
TWO THINGS CAN BE DREW AT THE
SAME TIME AND THAT'S WHAT
MADE --
>> Greg: IT'S FALSE BECAUSE
IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
>> Kennedy: IS HAPPENING NOW
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE USING IT FOR
THEIR POLITICAL ADVANTAGE BUT TO
YOUR POINT, PEOPLE HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
THESE PICTURES, THESE MONTAGES
HAVE EXISTED FOREVER.
AND JOE BIDEN'S DEFENSE, WHAT'S
YOUR GREATEST POLITICAL STRENGT
STRENGTH?
ON THE TURN OF A DIME IT BECAME
YOUR ULTIMATE WEAKNESS.
HOW DO YOU ADAPT TO THAT IF THE
THING YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN KNOWN
FOR, THE THINGS YOU'VE BEEN BEST
AT IS NOW SOMETHING THAT DEFINES
YOU AS A HORRIBLE PERSON.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DEHUMANIZE
HIM.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SHOWING VIDEO AT RALLIES.
HOW IS HE GOING TO HANDLE IT?
>> Dana: BE YOUR BEST SELF.